yeah I think two-man La is it's a it's a
unique place because of how uh the
unemployment stimulated people's pockets
during covid probably more than anywhere
else and once that went away I think
people a lot of people who weren't used
to living a certain lifestyle right they
got a taste of that lifestyle and um
and you know they're trying to keep that
I mean once you get a taste of having
that real money because there was people
eating off PPP like and and the EDD out
here
um so also too like you know I think a
lot of the obviously you know there's
people who are just
wrong place wrong time I think another
thing is is like kind of being just
self-aware of where you're at are you
gonna walk around with a hundred
thousand dollars around your neck when
somebody's starving right I mean you got
to kind of like understand like the
climate that's going on in LA right now
it's crazy because I used to feel like
when I go to New York I'd be like you
know New York is the place where you get
jacked and I'm not saying it still isn't
of course it is but I feel like La feels
like just a much more dangerous place
now even just going to New York we were
just like man it's so nice there's not
that many homeless people like there's
homeless people obviously we saw a bunch
but like certain areas of La it's like
it's it's like Skid Row all over but
there are Skid Row places in New York
I'm sure there are I'll take you there
next yeah I'm sure no I'm sure and and
every city has that right but I was we
were all over the city like if you just
drive around La which I'm sure you've
seen
it doesn't matter if you're in Skid Row
there's just 30 tents on the side of the
road there's like I mean but but you
guys don't have a subway system that
people live in this is true that's what
we have to now that's true the subway
system is a whole other variable people
that live underground as a matter of
fact years ago there was a movie uh made
called the mole men and it was a
documentary about people and I would
tell you myself one of the craziest
experiences I've ever had is I was 17
and I used to run with a bunch of wild
Dominican [ __ ] I mean talk
about cutting slicing get the [ __ ] out
of the way when you've seen all 30 of us
right and one day we were writing
graffiti at a place called
um the freedom tunnels which is on 72nd
Street it's all gentrified now but I
walk down the freedom Tunnel right and
when we were leaving we saw a dude just
coming out looking like [ __ ] like a like
a regular homeless dude yeah all [ __ ]
up yo and he had a plastic bag with him
right Kev he goes to one of the like the
the little fountains he washes himself
off Kev he takes out a hand towel and
uses it like a regular towel he puts on
a button-up shirt smacks on a name tag
puts a hat goes to work and gets ready
to go to work and we approached him
because I was like yo I want to ask this
[ __ ] something so we approached
him and he at first was like all right
you've seen 20 30 Dominican yeah he
thought he was gonna he was gonna
convict him right and I said yo yo we
don't want to do nothing to you bro I
said I just want to ask you something
and he was like what's up and I said you
really living in in the train tunnels he
said yeah there's 150 people down there
now he's like I'm one of the people that
lives there with my wife oh wow and I
said they got that in Vegas too so
there's like a whole city of people
underneath Las Vegas right so when I
asked him this I said wait a minute you
live with your wife down there and then
you guys and she's like yeah she has a
job as a waitress and I have a job
working at this spot where I like you
know I'm like a floor helper or whatever
and you know what that day I'm sitting
in the park where all my people is a
small while and now I'm just smoking the
hell thinking and I'm like
and they're like what's wrong and I'm
like you know that dude we ran into
and they were like yeah I said he's
doing better than me and they were like
what the [ __ ] you talking about he's
homeless I said no no no no
I asked the guy before we left I said
what's what's the goal he said you know
we can save up some money and then me
and my wife in like a few years we can
move out of there and we can try and get
our own place again get back on our feet
and I looked at the guys and I said
don't you understand bro y'all
[ __ ] out here looking for for
random broads this [ __ ] not only
found the love of his life but he found
a woman that really holds that standard
For Better or For Worse and not only
that yeah but y'all [ __ ] don't
got a plan this thing I got a plan
please yeah and I sat there and I was
like I don't got a plan and I don't
gotta ride or die
right what the [ __ ] am I doing right I
still live with my mom and dad I'm still
I'm still I'm still with a life
preserver on right this dude's swimming
in the ocean with wifey trying to make
it and it humbled me so much that I I
swear I have a such a a different
attitude dealing with people I talked to
a janitor the way I would talk I think
everybody should do that man right
because you never know like I always
tell that to people I'm like man you
never know who you especially you know
outside of just day-to-day real life
like I talked to Young Artists all the
time about just like treating the end
you got to treat the interns with
respect you gotta treat the engineers
with respect because you never know
who's gonna end up being the president
of your label one day or you know
whoever so yeah no that's definitely the
case even like up-and-coming artists you
know a lot of times people should like
go [ __ ] on up and coming artists like
it's like that could be the next whoever
the [ __ ] right they might or they'll
just go at the youth because they're
like I don't like this style or
something like that so I I know that
being from my era everybody when the
when the skinny jeans first came out
they were ripping these kids and I used
to joke with everybody I used to be like
listen
they might be wearing skinny jeans they
might even have a purse on but there's a
gun in that purse you got to be careful
with these little kids like you can't
just smack them up like there's nothing
you have to respect the fact that the
youth still they want to prove
themselves in something right and so you
know whether people make fun of them
here like the Edgars at Knott's Berry
Farm you don't want to get jumped by 50
or you're tapped into the Edgars you
don't want to get jumped listen fam
don't get jumped by 50 Edgars at Knott's
Berry Farm because that is not that's
not something that your your reputation
can recover from all right you're
getting beat up by gang members people
like all right what do you expect you
but you're getting jumped by children
don't do that you follow all the like
food communities and like all those IG
Pages who's going wild yeah big shout
out to Fool's going wild yeah yeah it
could be hilarious I think that but they
always have the Edgars fighting in knots
what's going on in Knott's Berry Farm
they like had to change the rules yeah
they made it so that you have to have a
big homie with you but that didn't
change that much because I could just
get the 20 year old homie to come right
right so you have to be accompanied by
someone over 21. yeah so you just got to
bring the big homie now